les amis bonjour bienvenue dans cette
vidéo je suis aujourd'hui avec un mytho
et mal fly les amis aujourd'hui on va
faire un truc assez drôle qui a déjà été
fait cent mille fois ok parce que
regarder cette vidéo mais regardez quand
même aujourd'hui on va tester les gars
notre amitié ou à voir si chacun pense
vraiment la même chose de l'autre un
exemple je dis qu'ils aiment jouer de la
guitare tu me dis mcfly c'est bien nous
qu'on pense pareil sur mac fly ok les
gars on commence qui est le plus apte à
pas mais ça commence comme ça roule pour
voir c'était dans la quille
premièrement qui est le plus apte à
pleurer en public 3 2 1 elle et moi je
suis très heureuse une qui est le plus
apte à oublier les anniversaires
quantités ont touché mes balles mais je
me suis levé et une anecdote horrible
pour les anniversaires va donc moi je ne
connais pas l'anniversaire de ma mère et
balancent pas toi t'es qui toi ok les
gars qui est le plus apte à être bourré
mois 3 2 1 alors primo pour toute la
communauté
l'abus d'alcool est dangereux pour la
santé ensuite ces derniers temps je bois
beaucoup moins ce qui est pire quand je
bois du coup elle a cessé tech pour les
autres voilà y'a pas de soucis on
enchaîne les interviews mis dans un taxi
comment en est il arrivé
il a dit allez on y va
[Musique]
qui est le plus apte à être fatiguée
elle a tout misé tous là non mais ça va
pas mal c'est sûr mais on est morts tous
les trois on a des vies difficiles vous
avions fait des vidéos sur moi je trouve
century magie parfait 2009 sur les jets
on rigole on rigole on n'a aucune
attache plutôt bien rémunérés sur notre
vie qui est le plus apte à être
impatients message à faire passer
c'était bien patient surtout quant aux
actes à jan tu fais ça écoutez ça et tu
trouves les onze ans que je suis patient
qui est alors celle a été nul je vous
préviens avant ce qui est le plus apte à
tomber quand une marche à toto entend
bonjour écoutez moi bien j'ai un
problème d'oreille interne pour le skate
le ski les rollers peut pas faire deux
virages à gauche il ya un vrai souci
faut faire ma vie à tintin mais toi
juste debout m 10 mai toi debout et je
faisais ça m'a dit un petit truc vous
regarde sans exagérer du coup j'ai
parfois j'ai le vertige de bouffon
s'écoule en tout cas les bons potes qui
se marre pas mais qu'il prenne soin
histoire qui est le plus apte à rire au
mauvais moment
oui cette image de 1,4 ou encore passé
un peu grand mère cantoria le visage qui
est le plus apte à péter en public
quand on fait régulièrement des paix
mondiale et produira des points virgules
toi tu es un bluff wayne on met les uns
plus céder j'aimerais qu'on parle de ce
qui s'est passé ce matin au réfectoire
7° préfet excusez moi je t'en prie non
mais il a raison pas
en 2017 non mais non mais je pense
bon alors les gars qui est le plus apte
à être un flop pour les filles vous êtes
très gentil mais je trouve très beau
rappel c'est ça le désir c'est vraiment
là vous avez du désir par donc est le
plus apte à pleurer devant un film
triste à rabat le mec qu'on est fragile
c'est ça l'image que faisait huit mois
est sensible c'est par défaut il avait
les femmes adorent les hommes sensibles
et moi vous avez mis moi non site ami
maurice trust me suis dit moi je pleure
devant des séries dans this is it your
way
moi j'ai pleuré devant sow aussi
simplement dévié le suspense et le
pleure quand tu es ce que tu as pleuré
devant ça mais bien sûr vous n'êtes pas
pleurer devant fin dans leurs activités
n'ont pas trop si je te dis qu'on va
plus travailler dans le bureau d'à côté
film allait maintenant là tu fais la
peur il ya un énervement ce qui arrive
et qui prend à sa fille de 21 ans qui
est le plus apte à parler aux animaux
et oui tu sais avec l'hygiène des petits
chiba le petit délire un petit peu
d'internet
je vais me dire j'ai besoin de votre
aide je me suis acheté deux poissons
rouges
oui je sais c'est la pire chose ma vie
il voulait trop et je vais acheter donc
je me suis acheté j'ai pas encore trouvé
de findus ouais mais il y en a deux
croustibat s'échanger résister pas nous
appelons résout vos problèmes leimer qui
est le plus apte à se marier à une
célébrité s comprend que l'intégration
de fait qu'on n'est pas célibataire
dans un discours absolue dans la
solution de la neutralité je m'appelle
jean michel bonjour bienvenue dans la
division je suis chiant
alors ces deux messieurs on doit être le
plus chiant possédant michel chiant
bonjour vous allez bien rock ou du coup
ça dépend du temps non mais t'as cima
vous mélangez tout je pose des questions
simples répondez simplement pas comme ça
c'est de quelle couleur ça sonne arpents
de patan des pontons quel est le chiffre
qui vient après 2,1 des pensions à
sénégalais beaucoup sa xv du set
masculin féminin
mais ce n'est pas un monde qui est le
plus apte à se marier de rédiger moi tu
vois pas tout ça quoi juste compris vous
aviez tort je me priverais toute ma vie
de sortir avec une fille connue c'est
con parce qu'il avait émis des roadshows
ce qui serait plus apte à mourir en
premier en cas d'invasion zombies mec
back to falling alors on est venus en
bus avec tes ce qu'ils sont gays moussa
sow aurait pu échafauder enfin raison
bitume avec une manette qui serait le
plus apte à être un drama king
c'est vrai on va rumex et au reboot et
toutes les réponses ou sociale et/ou
s'est complu comprend à travers les
réponses à ces questions quel point je
suis doux avec toi yes ciel s'est
installée nord c'était un peu vos de la
manade combe était surtout de ta vie je
te nique ta mère tout il a dit que la
visite au maire j'espère qu'ils la
voient du coup je voulais juste
il a dit qu'il adorait la cri de son
championnat qui serait le plus apte à
regarder d animer un retard mais dans
mes mecs ça c'est pas cool parce que ça
c'est à dire tu m'a pas écouté je ne
regarde pas d'animer je lis que les
mangas papier et melain ne veut pas dire
détester l'autre donc je respecte à fond
les anime et je n'ai pas le temps donc à
essayer de créer un conflit à partir
d'une source de pêche et au chili la
gueule au et les lacs et c'est pour
qu'ils connaissent en ce sens je te jure
c'est incroyable c'est toujours maître
intervient on va le parrain christopher
on va publier un truc sur sa chaîne qui
est le plus apte à avoir faim 24 heures
sur 24
trois jeunes a le plus évident de tout
ce qui est le plus simple à balancer ses
potes à la police parce que ça fait 48
heures qu'il est en garde à vue mais
t'es malade mais mettez un ouf ça ça me
saoule 20e il promis c'est toute la
france de vichy tfou non c'est toi petit
blanc mec là pour prendre et on envisage
le vrai tisane gestion très loi et non
tu te fous moi je peux caf à riga je
veux pas la job dating hockey attention
qui est capable de retenir son souffle
plus longtemps l'a321
je suis imbattable là dessus vous les
comparez en paix
[Musique]
briffaud un bouc en apnée en vidéo mais
pas l'eau et il a tenu une minute 41
mais tu m'as fait rire m'a fait très dur
mais je marque c'est la pire chose et
minute 53 pour qu'il démarre à chaud ce
qui est drôle c'est qu'en vrai en dehors
de l'eau je peux tenir hyper longtemps
mais dès que chute dans l'eau je tiens
vraiment plus longtemps on sait d où
c'était énorme
dernière question attention qui est le
plus fort en mathématiques aux autres
années mais qui a eu 80 points de retard
au bac
oui mais le bats et y ait quelques
années ils ont ensuite à fait vous oui
j'ai eu 4 enfin petit test rapide de
calcul mental la mesure el mago test no
84 x 6 merci d'avancé
amenez vos lacets de michael et au
lâcher de squeeze aussi on se retrouve
tous les dimanches matin mais alors pour
vous qui tient à 504
[Musique]